good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I am here with Lauren
Elizabeth hello a host of the toast and
a toaster herself so you have poised for
success today I am just a true toaster
every day every day every day how do you
how do you take a bite out of your
morning toast I take a bite out of my
morning toast around 1:00 p.m. okay at
least last time and I listen to it on
the podcast app gonna switch over to
Spotify clearly excited
it's exciting time but I listen to it in
the car I just started watching on
YouTube because I had to get the full
yeah Claudia doing her interpretive
dancing behind the bushes right no that
has to be seen to believe but how do you
feel youtubers podcast like you have any
notes for us anything I don't have any
notes it's definitely like interesting
what senior guys as facial expressions
on YouTube that I don't get to see on
the podcast so I would say if you're
listening to the podcast give YouTube a
try it's actually fullscreen egg you
just it's like watching TV it's great
and I might switch over but there's a
lot of LA traffic so right it's nice to
have both okay and you've been in New
York for a few days now and I feel like
people in LA are really like like
gung-ho about their traffic but I think
that New York traffic is worse you agree
yes oh my god don't you like LA traffic
it's like people in alleys like claim to
fame is like the traffic the traffic no
oh they talk about is the traffic the
traffic here is so much more horrible
and like not enough people talk about it
I try to talk about it once today on the
show just so that like you guys know how
bad we have it here and when I do make
the move to Cleveland what is with you
in Cleveland
I just see I've never been to Cleveland
right so you've never been no this is
just like a full-blown fantasy no but we
I was talking one night and like I
definitely I'm not like obsessed with
New York City I love it like for now but
I don't see myself being here forever
yeah because like just a the traffic and
like just the pace and you know people
everyone's angry and it just it seems
like anxiety and I just always feel like
I have my hands and fists you know and I
want to go somewhere where I'm like this
yes for the podcast listeners where my
hands are open and and so I was just
thinking like all across the country
like where could I move and there are so
many different suburbs of New York and I
just have a problem
with each suburb for a different ribbon
um like each one has their own stereo
yeah even like I feel like you're always
like kind of in the shadow of New York
you're trying to get to New York City
and I don't want to be somewhere where
I'm like thinking about being here right
so there's a lot of different great
cities in New York but I just feel like
Cleveland like has so many there's so
many different like shows and stuff
where people's lives have like just been
better from moving to Cleveland like
right Tina Fey 30 where she goes to
Cleveland and like she's so happy
then there's the show Hot in Cleveland
where literally the premise is that they
are hot in clean they're they're sexy in
Cleveland they're not in LA like and I
just ended Chloe new to Cleveland and
just seems so up that's when her life
really took a turn for the best right
where's Travis and Kylie like we're
talking in GQ about how when they first
started dating like they were on tour
and they were walking around they went
to Cleveland and they just walk the
streets of Cleveland they were able to
be themselves and it's just like
Cleveland sounds like this paradise well
I understand but like for me it's just
like LA is my paradise is it it really
cuz I'm from Chicago so like New York
doesn't appeal to me at all because I
get here in the smells just I hear you
oh my god like the humidity with this
smells like I'm constantly like I don't
know what to do with my mouth and my
nose and then I'm someone who like as
much as to be like oh my god people in
LA are the worst I'm like yeah like
everyone like cares how many like
followers they have an Instagram like
when you find the right parts like if
you don't go to West Hollywood you don't
have to deal with people that want to be
Kylie Jenner and then I live in
Brentwood and so I just get to be like
hey like how are you looks like I feel
like I'm the only one that said thank
you for my coffee this morning and like
New York in New York I think she was
like you're welcome I was like oh god so
sorry that I wanted to have like some
mall talk with you like it's just
everyone's so on edge and like doesn't
want to talk and I just want like chat
with my Bristo know I feel that and you
have like a good crew in LA that it
seems a lot you just like find your
people and like my one friend was always
just like I hate I hate LA I want to go
to New York and I was like like your
problems are gonna follow you there like
figure [ __ ] out right now she loves I
like and I feel like New York is even
harder there's just so much to sift
through and there's just smells and like
the traffic on that lease and I'll let
you have ways and you just like if you
can't take well sure or the 405 you take
somebody off you're never just sitting
stuck can't move
get out of the car like you're even when
I've been in traffic in LA like I mu I'm
going I'm moving you're moving around at
you're going left right like does it
enter with my podcast listening yeah but
then I know I get to listen for longer
because my nav interrupted you guys for
a second and I like that just saved me
30 seconds oh my God look every second
counts what we just like really long
episodes are bestest really oh my god
when I see it's like an hour and 30 I'm
like yes good like it's like when it's
that's like 47 minutes I'm like sorry my
guys like we get somewhere to me do you
have to bug you guys are always like
okay yeah like somewhere to go today
it's like we're not go quick I'm like
rude it's so funny because the show is
like really I think when we started was
intended to be we never had like a
format but like I would say 30 minutes
and then if there's a guest there's more
right but now it's like if we're at an
hour it's a good day yeah like it's a
normal day no I love it
the more the merrier go all day we're
gonna make this a long one then for you
guys oh god anyways but the thing about
New York they say is if you can make it
here you can make it anywhere and I feel
like I'm making you marry me here which
means me like I'll make it in Cleveland
and and now what now that you've made it
here drop everything
screw it start over easy go to Cleveland
I will not visit you in Cleveland no no
one will suburb maybe that's what I want
yes maybe that's my main plan I'm in
okay well thank you for professing your
love for the toast we love it right back
and we're so happy that you're here like
there's just so much exciting stuff
going on with you for those people who
don't know you what's what's the what's
the short bye what's the one-line Oh God
your Instagram bio my answer is I change
it a lot so I'm always like do I want to
be like full of myself or do I want to
be like quirky and then I like can't be
quirky and it's all things um I would
say like I started on YouTube so I
definitely am like a digital personality
but I also act of my Twitter BIOS I act
and create things so stupid I almost
changed it the other day but I was like
it really does subscribe what I do great
I do a lot of stuff so like I do to
traditional acting like movies TV series
whatever but then I do do unscripted and
then I have my clothing line and my home
decor alive and I still blog I just I do
everything nightmare well it sounds like
it's going really well you were wearing
your own clothing line today
yeah her pants are $58 yes don't they
look so fancy yeah they're fancy it's
really the matte black button I'm very
obsessed with it cuz it really just like
makes it a pant like imagine if this was
sober right and it's like my leg copping
out yeah that is so interesting I never
thought of it that way I don't like to
think about the details like that but I
guess that's what makes you a designer
exactly yeah just a procedures morning
show host yeah also fun fact the last
time Lauren came on the show she was
wearing leopard pants and now she's
wearing leopard top so she's always
giving her best leopard look yeah so I
just I I know I need to come through and
I'm on the toast yeah and you and you
totally doing you totally have and the
rest remains to be seen but yes let's
get into the fast guys story is that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast so you
don't get to hear it is it loud on the
oh my god wait I just remembered my
OneNote are you ready for it yeah
the volume needs to be higher and I saw
this in the toasters crib and I don't
comment on anything in the toaster screw
because I'm like too nervy and you know
it's overwhelming and also like then
people will be like oh it's like me and
then it's weird right
but it's you like I have to crank it up
okay so loud like you guys need to hire
the volume and then I put on a different
podcast and it's like more than the
radio you got and it's brutal so it's
like I'm going like this and I just want
to hear you Jackie okay so hey Jake you
got on the podcast a lot of people say
on their Bluetooth it's similar I think
that that's actually really easy to fix
like I think I can just before we upload
it put it in GarageBand up the volume
because send it yo guys
okay sure it's a toaster I actually have
seen those posts and the thing when
people are like I put it on all the way
high and then when my radio comes on the
next car it's horrible that's hilarious
yeah okay noted thank you
now we can jump in no now we're ready
for the stories our first story is about
the Emmys last night because apparently
they happened we didn't know didn't
watch because I think the Emmys are like
a little weenie I don't know why he had
to start what it's like they don't even
happen during award season right yeah I
don't even know what award season is
anymore though I feel like it happens
all year right and it like starts with
the People's Choice Awards and I get out
of the e the E's People's Choice Awards
right which like I guess is cool I guess
it's cool they had a really cool promo
commercial
like running commercial that was like
just being cool and I was like what is
this for and then it was for that I was
like okay I'm here for you I will watch
it I love a good rebrand and like easy
early on top of it their ship days yes
and I'll watch if it's sunny because
that's where I want the carpet and then
I usually like don't remember to go to
the actual award show right that's so
true you're watching me anyway yeah and
the Kardashians come on you just get
like sucked and you're like oh wait
these are still happening but I don't
really want watch Emmys because I don't
watch a lot of the shows that are
nominated right so I have no skin in the
game but here are some of the winners
and I actually do watch some of these
shows Outstanding Drama Series Game of
Thrones duh it's not another level do
you not watch was this is us nominated
for that it was that's my job I've never
seen an episode so like everyone tells
me I wouldn't like it
okay and I really appreciate you not
crying um / - I like crying I like I
enjoyed crying oh [ __ ] but I don't like
crying over like scripted fake [ __ ]
that's not actually happening in the
world and that's why I really like
reality because even though I'm sure
some of it's like you have played with
and edited yeah these are people's lives
and like I feel like when I'm investing
in Shannon beador stores Lightroom and
taking sides it's it's real as I post
like Mandy Moore's husband dying
question mark I don't know but it's like
that's not even her real husband but
it's just like it just pulls out your
heartstrings and other lates to your
life and that is like crying you're like
oh my god I've cried at script like I do
watch it yeah crap we chose Nashville
just ended the season the series finale
like really made me cry I forgot to talk
about this but they did an amazing job
I don't think ash - you don't need to
watch it to appreciate this finale so at
the end one of the main characters is
performing at the Grand Ole Opry which I
watched the first episode back and
that's where they opened the show so it
was full circle and then one by what he
like brings his dad on stage and then
his daughters come on stage and then one
by one the whole cast of everyone who's
ever been on the show and works young
age to sing the song and the creator of
the show was in the middle and it's like
it goes from me Nashville the show to
them just like being Nashville like
artists oh oh my god I was crying it
just like the show meant so much to so
many people and the town of Nashville
and she was just like we want to thank
the town of it just like when it was
like the hills of where it went from
being fake to real in one second you
know the characters are themselves but
now they get some of them really are
country artists like yeah I mean it
means he just came out with a song so I
just thought it was so well done first
last season that was very not good you
guys but you you really brought it to
back together I'll I mean I'm here for I
might YouTube that later it was really
cute very hillsides anyway so Game of
Thrones one drama CD watch Game of
Thrones no I tried you tried you're like
not very hard how many you have to give
it I would say 5 episodes if you're not
the least bit intrigued you can stop ok
I think I'm about to say five seasons
and I was like that's a years of your
life and then you can stop maybe I'll
try Outstanding Comedy Series the
marvelous mrs. Mazal yeah I never
watched it I think that's like an Amazon
show it isn't yeah I'm show but like
grateful just like bothers me I might
explain it I know I likes it great for
us great for her on our way okay but I
mean I can get behind it outstanding
limited series the assassination of
Gianni Versace which I did not watch but
I like recording all the episodes I
intended to but you know I stopped
watching when I got like a little dark
notes like going through some stuff and
I was like this is making me feel weird
and like sad and I had to like go back
to Bravo but what I did watch was
incredible
okay I wanna watch yeah I know cuz it's
really late I appreciate that so then
you can watch it and then like you're
history like yeah knowledgeable mm-hmm
exactly I done
Outstanding Lead Actress in a Drama
Series Claire Foy the crown well er do
you watch a crown I started and I'm
gonna I forgot to keep going so I'm
gonna keep going down it's so
interesting and now with like the megan
mark 1100 so are we gonna see that like
not really in like four years four okay
right now this next season they're
jumping forward so Claire Foy is not the
Queen anymore they're skipping 20
because they're bringing an all-new like
actor that was just an interesting way
to do things so I feel like this season
might be like Diana which is amazing oh
my god that's gonna be crazy
so when we when like all this Megan
Markel stuff came out I really wasn't
like up on the royal family I wasn't
like super interested I never really
cared about like Will and Kate and then
I started watching the crown and like
now I'm shocked by it all yeah I watched
like all these documentaries about the
warehouse when
and it's really so crazy so thanks Megan
forgetting me I wasn't like never ended
Megan Markel at the beginning I was like
very upset about it I was like why the
[ __ ] do we care about Megan Marco like
who gives a [ __ ] would be like Megan
Marvel's dog broke its toe today I'm
like oh since she's marrying Chris Harry
like I'm supposed to care about my
[ __ ] dog now where they were engaged
I really didn't care cuz I really that
was just like this hallmark actress yeah
good for her and I used to watch suits
so like that's why I also was like pega
Marco I've been watching her on my TV
forever and I never gave a shot and now
I'm like supposed to like be like
invested in her day-to-day life you talk
about her like she's like she gave up
her acting career what career his
Instagram is the best thing on the
planet
oh my guys tell so many people about it
and they're like who's Carrie Jannetty
I'm like that is so rude like it's the
best thing that's happened to our
Instagram you know it's so true and it's
just so honest thing no one's honest in
me I know I know and we need mean people
yeah not like to us even though it's
Mara's Yom Kippur and Margo and I were
here talking about how we're trying to
repent and talk less [ __ ]
but it's your show and it's my job and
if it's true it's not talking [ __ ] I'm
just stating facts right no it's just
like one way to think about it
Outstanding Lead Actor in a Drama Series
Matthew Rhys the Americans Outstanding
Lead Actress in a comedy series Rachel
Brosnahan the marvelous mrs. Mazal I
love saying her last name Wow Joe
Brosnahan really Outstanding Lead Actor
in a Comedy Series Bill Hader Barry
whatever I don't watch any of these
shows so I'm really glad that he didn't
watch it and yeah some of the Michael
che and Colin Jost hosted oh yeah and
you guys were like not here for that for
a while for a while we weren't into them
they went to this charity yes Robin Hood
and they hope they like get a set and
they were so fun yeah and I have a whole
new take on them now so now I even watch
like weekend Upton and I and I smile
more at them and I was when we announced
and they were doing the Emmys I was
actually excited about it because I'm
really happy colin jost like will work
another hour this week right and you
know maybe live up to ScarJo but they
were being PDA as hell on the red moon
like they won't they walk together
I don't like do people still so ship it
yes anti-ship it's not that I anti-ship
like I just like it I feel like a mommy
son vibe from them and I'm like the
short hair is just like she's like -
like sexy and fierce and it's like he's
just like a little nerdy but like I'm
sure that they love by these days like
Breanna heat and like salmon guy and
Victoria's Secret oh yeah it's like
starting at trying to know like people
are starting to get engaged it's so
weird
really my friend literally was like oh
yeah like our friend so-and-so who's
like dating you know it's the singer guy
whatever
oh yeah I think they're gonna get
engaged soon I was like is that
literally just because of like everyone
getting engaged she's 20 yeah I was like
what's going on it was like maybe
that'll give me a ring sooner I don't
know yes because no one in LA gets
engaged that's like really yeah like
even my boyfriend will be like it's like
my friends will come in town from
Chicago in there like so when you guys
getting married and he's like Lauren
like you know they we're just like from
different parts like you know and I'm
like oh okay like if we lived in Chicago
we could get engaged right now I'm gonna
be like I'm like okay I'm gonna be
living in Cleveland like looking for
like a new boyfriend when like Cameron
doesn't propose in the next seven years
wow I didn't realize that was it thing
about LA yeah cuz like everyone's like
it's like Hollywood but I do feel like
tides are turning yes and I'm excited I
feel like for a while it was like 25
just like felt like so young and yeah
you know but I don't know I feel like
now definitely Bieber Ariana Grande
are really changing things for anything
it's like a nice trend to said okay well
that's like a wife each other up right
instead of like cheat on each other all
the time
right like I partake in that but like LA
is very it's very Chiti it's just like
it's not a bad stuff going on that's why
I don't like I like that you say above
it I do I do
speaking of getting each what a segue
there was an ounce each proposal at the
Emmys on ok is uh so moments after
winning the Emmy for outstanding
directing for a variety special for his
work on the Oscars Glenn Weiss asked his
girlfriend Jan sped since marry him oh
this is a photo of the two of them like
he looks like kind of hipster like as
you see what I'm talking about mark yeah
do they live in LA look how old they are
getting engaged right that is not Justin
Bieber in hailey Baldwin that is Mama
and Papa right that's just me very Haley
Baldwin's parents yeah well that is so
crazy and I know that if Claudia we're
here she we just want me to mention that
this
is a very thirsty act yeah it's like
Maria Menounos getting married rockin
Eve special and I think she would use
the term yeah no this is pretty this is
pretty looser I'm not gonna lie I didn't
watch the video sorry maybe if I watch a
video I would like tug at my
heartstrings no but like why did why do
I I've never heard of you Glen lace like
why should I be watching your engagement
in all the people in the audience like
do you think that like Jessica Biel and
Justin Timberlake like gave a [ __ ] like
oh no it's it's weird what did it win
like was designing the ring right hockey
for her like she has to wait a whole
nother year yeah just in case not much
time in LA what's another year what's
another year but no this seems really
thirsty especially for like people who
Teknik behind the Suzy that's I know - I
mean listen it's nothing without the
crew but still like you're doing it in a
place for like the celebs to shine and
it's like a little and you've chosen
like a life less thirsty yeah so why now
why this thirst right I wonder if I'll
ever get through a show without
referencing that line from Legally
Blonde why now why this firm I was like
I was like every day a thirst burger it
got her okay um anyways she said yes
thank God if we were all at the
engagement we should all be invited to
the wedding
true can't wait okay next story is
something that's really taking the world
by storm sort of ish I mean no one
really cares but we've been pronouncing
ariana grande and Chrissy Teigen named
wrong this whole time did you see the
story all this um my phone this morning
and I was like is it really true or like
are we misinterpreting Chrissy's he gets
tweet well I I think at first when I saw
that she tweeted it I was like oh she's
obviously [ __ ] with what I thought -
I thought she was kidding but I don't
think she's kidding
she she said she gave up a long time ago
but her last name is Tigan not Teigen oh
it really it really is I don't like it I
don't like it even better and right it's
like we're doing at her a favor like
Chrissy Tigan it sounds like tiger or
like a brand of like detergent yeah Tugg
in ultra like I don't know like it's
just Chrissy Teigen like a rolls off the
tongue I
totally agree and it's funny now that I
think about it like I'm a hundred
percent sure that we pronounce our last
name wrong really at least but we
started like we say ASHRAE just cuz like
I prefer and I don't know like an AA
instead of an O yeah in general like
that very uh my axe right so I'm sure
it's like oshri so other people will say
like they'll pronounce they'll be like
Jackie Oh she'd be like did I get that
right I'm like actually you got it right
and I get it wrong I like I'll sure
though
I like I sure I do I'm sure sounds like
a river yeah but what's interesting it's
so our name like is a Hebrew word and
it's a prayer called but the prayer
starts out ashrae oshri so it's like
literally so I guess we're both right
yes yes yes so you just have to like
well let people say whatever they want
but I just can't believe she never like
she yes she directed people ever right
well she said I know I even correct up
she said I don't correct people ever
they can call me Janet and I won't
correct them wrong order I'll eat it
taxi going to the airport right like oh
that was me Wow okay I'm usually not
really here for her but like that isn't
literally me that is my personality in a
nutshell if someone's if I like order
coffee and they're like oh did you want
whole milk and I'm just like mm-hmm and
like we'll just like throw it away and
go to a new like coffee place and like
get a new coffee right if they like
right in the wrong order I'm like well
like I can't eat this - yeah you know
it's I can't who did I sound like I have
another I was like in a meeting
yesterday
and he said something and I like my
boyfriend like corrected him and I said
are you doing like no like you just go
with it the person's always right like
totally I'm just that person oh my god
I'm so that person - and Zac is the
total opposite yeah it's like if I get a
wine and I don't like it so I'm not
gonna drink it but it's like they
brought me I ordered this wine they
brought me the right wine like ooh am I
to send it back and he's like you have
you send it back I'm like huge hand I
know I think yeah what do I say like I
just don't like it yeah then I ordered
it don't worry things you're if I know
you weren't gonna like it or like it but
the deed is done the deed is done you
need to drink no it's something that I'm
really working on I've definitely gotten
better
I'm a little better at restaurants
because it's like I do love food and
wine so like if it's really bad but like
sometimes if it's a little too smooth
I'm like
oh here we go right and then it's like
last night they were like oh do you want
red or white and I was like I don't care
like whatever like you know what I mean
like where I was like I would have
totally been able to choose myself as
like whatever you want me to drink and
they're like okay here's red and I was
on camera and I was like my teeth are
gonna get read my lips are gonna get red
and I just I'm gonna happen Wow mm-hmm
that's that's Wow that's said another
level so I don't know what that's gonna
look like I feel like you'd be like
aggressive though cuz like you're so
aggressive in like I feel like in work
and like just like taking the helm you
know I feel like you wouldn't be shy
like I'm shy ya know I'm not shy I think
that like in certain situations
situations
I want to pretend that I'm shy right I'm
always I'm so shy like what are you
talking about like I'm like nacho that's
so funny
also ariana grande's name is entirely
ariana grande II know it is yes yes it
is
who's confirmed this it seems Chrissy
Teigen and pop star Ariana Grande
unexpectedly had this in common in a
recent interest interview with Ebro
Darden for apples beats one the song
just revealed that her name too has been
said wrong her entire career but not by
accident quote I have to keep Grande
because my grandpa I think of him with
everything I do when he was so proud of
my name I should keep it i'ma keep it
she told dart and when he asked her
about taking Pete Davidson's name when
they get married
quote my grandparents said grandi my
brother Frankie kind of changed it to
Grande because grandi was kind of like
the American guys version of it she
explained
I grew up saying grandi that is so
imagine her name was Arianna cranny
Miami
it's just sounds like I can see her
grandparents saying it like right where
are the varieties like why what is so
grand 'is the Americanized version so
grande is what we're home from I know
and I feel like they that's just and
especially since Frankie started it
right he's so like right he's like we're
gonna be granted and also like Starbucks
like I just really like that's the easy
way to like see that word and we all
drink Starbucks sobre Grande that would
be like confusing and annoying for us if
like they weren't two different ways on
D it sounds awful I'm sorry no offense I
don't [ __ ] with Starbucks anymore but
like when I used to
I think the last time I saw bucks must
have been like three years ago and I was
like living in like three Martin's about
yet but like I literally hated it so
much you're gonna drink this week let me
tell you oh my god you're so right no
but now I have a Keurig okay yeah and
but I would never ever use their words
like I would be like I will have a large
or an actual like I I just I felt so
stupid like sandy yeah I'm always like
I'll be tall of a venti at Renta 20
trying to treinta that's like I would
hope that's the guzzler yeah that's the
guzzler yeah oh I love a good guzzler
but they're there coffee tastes like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] litter laughs no like I
don't I don't understand how they get
away with it and it's like everyone's
drink Starbucks but like are you guys
finishing your cups of coffee you have
to get like a sugary drink and feel
horrible about yourself or just like not
go to Starbucks yeah you can like
traveling a lot like at least you know
what you're getting right which is why
I'd still drink Starbucks that travel so
much and usually like I have no idea
where I am or where I'm going are like
oh and I hate my life and then I'm like
well Starbucks at least I know what I'm
getting myself into
yeah that's true at least you know
you're getting a piece of trash as
opposed to a surprise like a surprise
piece of trash I don't need that I need
to know the exact piece of trash that
I'm putting into my system right I guess
if I'm traveling and it's like I need
coffee so badly I'm like glad to see you
start but exactly because it's just it's
like home you're it's like America but
also Dunkin America runs on America runs
on Dunkin I saw the Dunkin Donuts in the
airport and my boyfriend said keep
walking know it's like [ __ ]
Duncan I think I prefer Dunkin iced
coffee over Starbucks yes see I've never
had I just dude the doughnuts Oh trail
and they knew had they have like a new
egg and cheese right I don't eat lemon
there's not much I can eat like for
breakfast at dunya because like I don't
eat meat so like but Zach ones been torn
up and it was like so good really yeah
it's really gonna make fresh chasing it
you wouldn't expect that it's like gonna
be nuts I'm like I'm from Illinois so
like I'm I run on a pole a Panera Dunkin
like all these things that like are so
not LA so I'm just like so excited to
eat them whenever I get out of it's like
these things don't like Dunkin Donuts
the first one in LA I opened up by me
like two years ago why there's nothing
one Dunkin donut la does not run on
Dunkin la does not run on Dunkin we run
on but first coffee
that's so yeah what about the coffee
there's a lot of those I've never been
to I mean the coffee bean was like
really cool four years ago when like
paparazzi pictures would always have the
purple straw everyone's like Oh coffee
bean like LA but now with this whole new
wave of like the warrant I'll rise and
for us to do the Alpha hasn't even made
the move to not plastic straw for that
early New York - it depends where you go
what is your stance where do you stand
in the war on straws I just feel like I
listen I'm here for like positive change
like the fact that people are like doing
something with their lives it's like
fantastic but it's just such a small
problem and it's also it's also such a
big solution for so many people you know
like getting rid of shot smell solves a
very miniscule kiss point zero one
percent are under promises but using a
straw sobs like 50 percent of my life
have you seen the new Starbucks like
tops they're horrible I've noticed it
and it's like and you're like it's like
drinking cold soup it's disgusting I
hate it I know people in LA like I know
you're upset
I hope they suffer for it they will
you're like I'm not gonna ever carry
around metal straws oh my god they're
like no but it's like the bacteria like
anything wet like I'll carry around a
disposable straw yeah maybe one that's
not made out of plastic but I will not
[ __ ] with the paper try either mm-hmm
that is where this warnings to end right
someone was like what are we gonna do
like we need to replace paper straws and
I just replied being like let's try
plastic and everyone was like that's the
opposite of I was kidding I understand
the point right but like let's just
switch it back and then like we'll make
the cups out of something else I don't
know right I just I don't know I'm not
like a world problem solver
no me neither but I Adrian Grenier has
like inserting himself into yes and I
just want to like be on the other end
for some reason also cuz I really enjoy
straw is also someone wrote that they're
trying to buy your pants and they can't
find them where XLE the label calm even
so the website does this like really fun
thing where when something sells out it
just disappears off the website
oh well they mistletoe and they're I
guess they might be sold out but like
some stuff maybe like is like
reappearing I don't really know maybe
like check back later if you don't see
them now but usually it means it's sold
out look we have like 35 products now we
only have like
twenty-eight or something well that's a
great problem to have it is it's good
it's just I think it's a confusing
instead of seeing something like sold
out it's just right it's gone so I put
in the request to change that but
parently no one listens to me well
congrats on having a wonderful problem
okay this next story a little more in
the Les Moonves saga because I wouldn't
be a show without Cespedes
Julie Chen is reportedly leading the
talk after husband les moonves's CB s
exit reports enews Julie China's poised
to lead to talk according to reports
Chen the wife of former CBS honcho les
Moonves has not appeared on the daytime
talk show since her husband's eyes it
from the network was announced moonves's
exit comes after a second round of
sexual misconduct allegations brought to
light by Rowan Ferro unum stories in The
New Yorker while China's in sat
alongside co-host Sara Gilbert Shannon
Osbourne Eve and Shara Underwood on the
talk she did appear in her other regular
CBS gig hosting Big Brother when she
signed off as good night I'm Julie Chen
movement notice so she obviously you
know I really I only know about this
story from listening to the podcast like
even while you were talking about it I
was like I don't watch Big Brother I
don't watch CBS like I don't really know
what you're talking about but like I
understand but context cuz I like
listening right but I'm still like don't
really know so that's where I'm at too
because I would like there have been a
lot of like you know falls from grace
sexual misconduct allegations and we
don't talk about all of them we talk
about the ones that like of people that
really matter the most to us right that
we like that they're you know
Lackland stream right or like Kevin
Spacey not being on house of cards like
I'm gonna notice that I want raps of
cards you're like some other actor that
I don't know like so we and also talk
about every like piece of Hollywood this
would be called the Hollywood piece of
[ __ ] this is oh welcome the hall that I
was seeing so much stuff about Les
Moonves like I'm a notification said I
was like okay clearly this is like a
really big story and then the big
brother Zhu Li Chen Moonves of it all
so I decided to talk about it also I
enjoy saying Les Moonves yes and I
actually I was giggling the whole time
it's so funny les Moonves like I don't
even like is that it sounds like a play
like I don't know no it's like the
sequel
ladies this is hilarious but but she's
leaking ly talking honestly I mean as
someone out here like thirsting to be on
a talk show how dare you write like
you'd like don't bite the hand that
feeds you or not there's now a seat open
on the talk that's what I'm saying like
this actually kind of benefits you right
we've caught you on the dust and like
get your audition tape and well what
time actually I don't I mean could you
double I could I feel like I could have
like an afternoon show but I just I
don't know if these are my people but
anyways you know I could I don't think
it'd work I don't know I don't know
Sharon Osbourne is my people but you
know I can I can read for them it's just
like every whenever all this stuff comes
out in Hollywood it's just like it's
like the jig's up you know what I mean
like now it's it's it's truly like a
different like climate as in the sense
of like you really like are like more
perspective and like like this like
affects like my day-to-day look I was
like an [ __ ] weird does it and yeah
like it's just like first of all like
all these people like claiming that like
they never knew or like it's just like
it's it's BS I'm like I was 19 years old
and I like had an Inc like met Harvey
Weinstein at a party and like I was Tara
I was chilled to the bone and like I
like men like wanted me to meet him so
that they would pay attention to what
they had to say since like I was
standing there like and if I know what's
going on it's like a 19 year old from
like Illinois with like no connect like
whatever Georgina Chapman yeah Gweneth
Paltrow knows what's going on like
please and so it's just like this
immoral street we have a Meryl Streep's
like I didn't know Michael you do like
and like listen like I'm not like coming
after anyone but I'm just like it's a
small town like people talk like I've
been hearing about stuff like for years
before any of this stuff came out and
I'm no one
I'm on the lowest of the totem pole and
so I'm just like but it is nice that all
that's coming out because like I work on
set and like I work with producers and
it's like it's truly it's like it's so
great being a little bit like time's up
like you can't treat me like that
anymore like and it's crazy so it's just
like I'm here for it because then I
don't have to deal with like creepy
people anymore hey I haven't spoken to
anyone who's like actually been affected
by it like a personal level in the
workplace with people just like when I
take advantage just it's weird you know
it's like
like let's go to drinks or like let's
hang out offset or like it's just you
there's no really lions and their been
so blurry all this time and now that we
have like actual lines because so many
people are getting in trouble
right it's like nice like I'm not to let
your hotel room yeah and like you don't
have to go to set and like be worried
anymore whereas like as a 19 year old
I'd be like oh my god like you're like
being so unprofessional you're making me
uncomfortable like leave me alone and
I'd be like pissed and it was just like
nothing like crazy obviously but just
like stuff of like who's like do you
have a boyfriend and I'm like we're at
work right if we're at work like we're
at work this is our jobs we just cuz
we're actors doesn't mean you can like
be like loose so like I think you should
like you know build our chemistry offset
I'm like no I'm acting like I don't have
to like you because I'm acting and so
now it's just like it's so nice that
like men don't have to like be
interested in me anymore
so do you think like even though there
are definitely creeps out there who
haven't been called out yet like they
their time hasn't come do you think
they're being less creepy yeah it's like
not everyone but like there's definitely
I think at least like women too we're
just kind of like the jig is up
we're like you don't have to do like I'm
like the whole that whole shtick is over
you know and yeah it's like either
people are like trying to figure out how
to be less creepy I mean some people are
just like sick in the head so you can't
really fix that right I think it's like
definitely like a nice change of pace in
LA where you like you can't get away
with as much stuff and it's nice well
I'm still glad to hear that and now I'm
gonna keep I mean I've contributed
nothing other than talking about it I'm
gonna keep door busting so that it's
easier thank you you're making my life a
lot easier it's not that you know men
are fawning over me it's just you really
just have to like be a female's Rowan
Pharaoh is making a lot of people's
lives
yes easier I thought his name was Ronin
yeah me too I think he [ __ ] up I don't
that Ronit no I mean Rowan sounds right
hold on let me just google it Rowan
Pharaoh no a ronin no it's Rowan in a
[ __ ] up you guys yeah good morning
toast always doing justice
oh wait Ronan Barrett like he's changing
the game for so many people out there
and you can't even get his name right
yeah seriously what else is
Time's Up Kids time's up exciting okay
next story is also exciting and now with
where we ship to like a little business
loose how have you been feeling about it
I've been loving it and like I feel like
I know things in like sometimes I'm just
like oh I only know that that's because
the morning toast people probably think
I read the news but like it's good but
the my boyfriend the other day was like
what are you talking about he'll almost
like doesn't do drugs and I'm just like
first of all I read the blinds and I
listened to the chose to like I'm just
like have you not been seen like what's
going on on like Twitter and like all
this stuff and he was like I think the
stock went up the other day my friends
were like oh yeah what's called apples
like the only one trillion company I was
like I'm pretty sure I heard that like
Amazon was like you're like whatever
guys you guys reported on it like I am
smart as hell now oh my god I'm dead and
now I'm you gotta keep at it it's like
you guys are still funny about it so
it's very boring no and we enjoy it
because there's only so much we can say
about Ryan and Pia and Justin and Haley
and that's this now like we when we talk
about like a cereal then like it brings
us out to our childhood it opens up like
new pockets of our brain and I have like
conversation starters now oh my god oh
did you hear what's going on with like
Ritz and goldfish people are what and
I'm like Salmonella or like whatever
like I just like Micah that's how you
get salmonella people like what are you
talking about and I'm like like listen
am I always like I listen to the toast
no I pretend that I've know great things
cuz I'm smart but that's really where
it's coming from
oh my god wow I didn't even realize all
of that okay now I'm just like really
[ __ ] dumb and I don't read the news
and I'm the only one affected it's like
once we made this [ __ ] we did one
business story once and then we were
like wow we should do this more it's
like now when I'm pulling stories yes I
do like page six people enews but I also
do like CNN Money
yes I know these others so like I also
feel like these are stories I wouldn't
know about right on the toast either so
these educating me as well and this next
story is very exciting
Koch is considering cannabis drinks the
world's largest beverage makers
reportedly eyeing the red hot cabinet of
this market according to a report
coca-cola is in serious talks with
Aurora cannabis to develop cannabidiol
infused beverages according to bien and
Bloomberg a deal on that scale would
likely dwarf agreements made by Corona
maker consolation brands and Molson
cools both of which who have partnered
with Canadian cannabis companies to add
CBD the night the non psychoactive
ingredient in cannabis that can be used
to treat treat pain or anxiety to drink
sigh coffee soda and beer and would
resent a quote mainstreaming of pot
products in the eyes of Wall Street for
coke getting into the wheat market would
be both capturing a trend and a
diversification play soda sales have
been down as younger consumers seek out
healthier drinks like sparkling water
shares of Aurora were up to over six
percent on the news Monday morning as
where other socks like till right this
comes from cheddar another source that I
known to a lot for Business News this is
crazy this is exciting and at first I'm
not I don't smoke pot but like I don't
do it I don't like judge people who do
it's just like not my personality but
you know what this beverage sounds like
my personality like something that like
a drink that has the exact opposite
effect of caffeine is like a chamomile
tea that like just makes you relaxed I
mean look we already have this stuff in
LA obviously so allow you yeah we have a
bunch of luck drinks that have CB even
like at the coffee shops now which is
like Stumptown coffee and like stuff
like that you can get CBD like syrup
just like in your coffee Oh interesting
I think I'm so has they have something
like that yeah yeah make friend tried to
order it they were out of the CBD it was
a cannabis brownie on the Ace Hotel many
out in New York I was like is that legal
that tides are really turning I was like
so confused is it I don't know I I don't
know I would do like I don't I don't
mess with that stuff like yeah it's it's
not my personality they're like I have
too much anxiety and like stress and I'm
like why she was like I need a glass of
wine to like calm down I cannot smoke
cuz I'll let go insane but CBD
definitely is very different like you
would like it right it sounds like I
would like it because it doesn't make
you high it just makes your body calm
but the problem with CBD and like the
drinks though that I've at least noticed
is if there's not a little bit of THC
it doesn't really like activate it so I
feel like you have to at least have a
maybe have a lot of CBD so like we
always have like a little bit of like
the THC in it so that like you don't get
high but it like activate its I don't
know like when we add there it's like
exactly but like we have tons of CBD
drinks in LA and they're just really
nice they're good for your digestive
system and like your anxiety
honestly I'm really here for it which is
so and also this is so crazy because
like people used to say that back in the
day like coca-cola like had cocaine in
it yeah so this is like a full 180
it really is it's like big go from like
having cocaine to having CBD which is
the exact opposite and they feel
it says a lot about like our society
that day it's like you wanted to be like
wow it's like we're also like anxious
and like we have all these different
like streams of things like to serve our
mental health that this is what we need
right now and that the largest beverage
company in the world feels that way and
I feel like people trust it too like
there's so many like parts in America
where like no one would probably ever
[ __ ] with CBD but if coca-cola is like
endorsing it and like that's like a
company they trust that's not if it
could really like I'm one of those
people yeah I would never order a drink
with CBD because I don't know enough
about a bit of coca-cola and their
research team is telling me like this is
as mainstream as diet with lemon then
you're like okay I'm gonna drink CED
lemon is it CBD as normal as lemon yeah
we've pretty much is it's like from a
plan right that's so crazy it's like
really good for you oh my gosh so do you
watch billions we started it so I've
watched like part of the first season
that's where I was until three days ago
I'd only watched the first season like
two years ago and now I'm like binging
it I just started season 3 and so like
this is something that ax would have
like picked up on like Aurora and like
he would buy shares and then this news
would drop you know so maybe I should
buy some shares of Aurora you should buy
some we chairs for sure yeah you think
it's you think so mm-hmm
my boyfriend is very good at like
picking like stocks and like all that
stuff it's like and I get you socks for
your birthday like Kanye did for him
I've honestly been thinking about I'm
like more of a jewelry girl but like I
don't think I'd be mad at a few stocks
cuz like I'm just like too lazy you know
like I know it's what I should be doing
but I'm like yeah that helps but that
was like I mean that was really cute
when Kanye did it for cash no we're
looking McDonald's Disney adidas a
detangle Apple Amazon that you that yeah
brilliant yeah that we know because we
watch the toes right but I like I like
it for like I mean when you're like so
rich and you have everything like you
might as well get stocks you think so
yeah I mean it's like they're like
getting each other cars all the time
because it's like there's nothing more
lavish for them like getting jewelry is
like literally nothing to that wears
like to me I'm like oh my god I'm like
wow but for them it's just like give
them a car
Bentley right it's like get them stocks
that money's gonna grow or it won't
either way it's exciting you know and
like it is it's it's there's opportunity
right the American dream
it is the American dream and this is
like just I feel like a really big shift
that coke I mean it's not like I don't
think this for happy for a long time you
don't I mean I don't know if how one say
I mean this news is now public I feel
like Oklahoma's fine with that so like
it's sure how long are they gonna sit on
it and someone else like might take the
idea that's also very true maybe you're
right and I guess that's legal like it's
not it's not psychoactive so maybe it'll
happen in like 2020
I can't wait that'd be weird to think
about drinking soda as a relaxant cuz
right now I try not to drink soda like
after if I I only have one soda a day
and like I turn it totally just cuz like
I don't need anything else to keep me up
yeah you know I want like sleeping is my
favorite thing in the whole world whole
world and I don't want to do anything to
disturb it what time do you wake up to
get to this show I set my alarm for
about 8:30 depending on a day the latest
I can roll out of bed is like 905 and
today was one of those days I got the
bun cuz I like was I was like I was a
kind of Rohan like waking up on time I
got I woke up at 8:30 or maybe eight I
don't know I was just like I don't know
New York traffic yeah and also you're a
little bit like further west from the
studio that I am so I know how long it
takes me to get here that I can get it
pretty good Louis you're not waking up
at like 7:00 no I know you like clams
like I don't know maybe she's an early
riser I like lamb but my this makeup
which I wear for everything in life like
even my own wedding probably um takes me
now like 2025 minutes Oh easy
how long does your makeup take you like
15 they did a lot of like finger
painting oh yeah do you when you use
foundation your skin looks amazing by
the way and I'm excited to talk about
makeup this is a good segue like use a
blender use your hands
I honestly like and I get like sent so
much stuff which is just it's easy for
me to like use a Beauty Blender and like
with my children right grab me one the
next day my sink goes crazy
she's like you literally use a Beauty
Blender and then go to a clean one I
have like all these like things but I
like when I travel I'm like an idiot so
I keep forgetting brushes so I've been
using my fingers and I watch em Radha's
like Vogue thing and she's like yeah
like my husband calls it finger painting
I do it with my hands and I was like
well dry Marana can do it I can do it I
didn't watch hers was it good it was
actually pretty good for like fur being
like a supermodel usually they like put
chapstick all over their face right
huntington-whiteley pudding like so red
tinted chapstick on her lips and I'm
like stop like I don't like I was like
show me something good like Rihanna or
Kylie yes but she just kept being like
it's like it's just like I love my good
like oh this is why I love makeup and
like this is how I got into makeup I'm
like oh my god we get it like you like
makeup for people that don't need makeup
like yeah it's all those people on vogue
right that I don't need to watch right
I'd watch like you two really different
person without makeup Oh series II and
it changes my personality do people
recognize me sometimes um I hope people
don't write like legitimately I look
like different versions of myself with
like a spray tan without a spray tan
with makeup without makeup it's like I
feel like you do you're kind of like
have a chameleon look - yeah with blonde
hair with brown hair and like sometimes
I really don't know what's working for
me or what's not but like people like oh
I recognized you cuz of your voice
cuz they watched my videos interesting
I'm like oh that's what you're like
Hannah Montana
I like people all the time say that my
voice sounds like Hannah Montana not
Miley Cyrus Hannah Montana it's like
still to this day I hear it a little bit
like I love Hannah Montana Cameron will
see you like Miley Cyrus like at Soho
House or something and he'll like turn
around cuz he said oh [ __ ] it's my
annoying girlfriend here and then he's
like oh god it's Miley Cyrus cuz he
thinks it's like the same voice it's bad
that's great
that's great right okay the next third
and final story yesterday we talked
about how Elon Musk was announcing the
first private citizen who was gonna be
taking a spaceship trip Oh face a
private person not an astronaut and it
is tech Billy meet the tech billionaire
who will be taking SpaceX's first moon
tourist
Japanese billionaire yuusaku Misawa has
made a name for himself as a rock
musician and online fashion mogul and
now Earth's first moon tourist the 42
year old type tech tycoon made headlines
Tuesday when SpaceX revealed that Misawa
has chartered a flight aboard the
company's big Falcon rocket which is
still being developed for a slingshot
trip around the moon as soon as 2023
he's planning to take six to eight
artists with him and he won't be
charging them for the ride quote I want
to share this experience in things with
as many people as possible Misawa told a
news conference quotes
I chose to go to the moon with artists
Misawa made his fortune in e-commerce
but his first love was music an industry
in which he made the transition from
artists to entrepreneur little bit of
backs where he started an indie rock
band in high school
released an EP in 1993 he skipped
college to follow his then-girlfriend to
the US where he started collecting fees
and records of bands he liked when he
returned to Japan in 1995 he started an
import music business selling CDs and
vinyls of his favorite bands bands by
mail from his home ok so interesting
choice I don't know who I expected to be
I kind of expected to be some like Joe
Schmo yeah but like in Zemun he's like I
want to like share this experience with
artists I'm like are you doing drugs
moon look they're all gonna be like oh
that's like when you're like so rich and
you run out of things to do let me go to
the moon go to a different planet but I
thought I thought to you like it was
gonna be a Joe Schmo and then you were
like tech billionaire also I think he
had to pay for his spot so whoa I think
so because like Tesla is not getting out
rides for free like therapy yeah I the
company they got to make that money but
like I was I can't believe that like
tourists are going going to the moon I
feel like also it's like like a claim to
fame thing they're like I want to be the
first Taurus to go to the moon totally
it's like like a big dick big dick
energy totally well that's really
exciting for him like I wonder what
they're gonna do up there I wonder how
long it's gonna be how long a house that
I need to happy in this picture oh my
god what are your thoughts on Elon have
you met him no I don't like that with
have you met ever
and have you met Grimes nah none of the
above I have friends that have met Elon
like at parties and stuff how do you men
you know oh but like I just like I don't
I don't not like in that scene you know
I'm like young right we'll see you
really had fun Joey King scenes yeah Wow
with abhar we just like hang out and
like do stupid [ __ ] I'm not like going
to like parties where people think
they're like too cool for school you
know got it but Ilana I just feel like
looks like did you see the meme where he
looks like before he was famous and
after yes and like that's I can't get it
out of my head anymore that he that he's
really that guy look at all day and then
it's like he is so smart I don't know I
just think I just think he's like what's
the world what's the word and
come on enigma I'm he's an enigma
wrapped in a riddle and cash
yes a lot of cash but I don't know he
scares me
he scares me but I like my Valen I
really like it he has so much power but
I just I don't know I really like him
and they think that he's smart and we
reported yesterday on the morning shows
Instagram and literally nobody gave a
show because it's my worst performing
post of all time but that guy that Verne
Unsworth the British driver who he
called the pedo is about him oh yeah oh
yeah it's interesting it's interesting I
just like can't believe he that goes on
Twitter and like makes all these like
statements and he was like Elon Musk
right like you can't just like tweet
right I do not have a publicist no but
it's like he can't just meet but he also
can cuz he's cousin on us and I believe
what he said and he's changing the world
and he's gonna make it take like 45
minutes to get from New York to LA and
you know what yeah that's something I
can get behind that's real properties
makes that happen I'll vote for
president like that's games like we
haven't had an innovation like that like
since the railroads you know or since
like the Wright brothers on their little
plane okay you know like we've been
dealing with like like as much as like
we're so forward-thinking like we
haven't had like a big invention yeah
while yeah and like we're dealing a lot
of [ __ ] the internet internet like
traffic straws Palouse like we have a
lot of [ __ ] to figure out and Elon Musk
is really helping us with a lot of
things right so you know what if you
need to like do drugs and yeah it takes
to Twitter if that's gonna get us Ellie
faster personally I'm here for it I
understand if not everyone is like I
understand people our team burn or just
like over Elon or think he's like lost
it but I'm gonna I'm gonna ride it out
with him yeah I'm gonna ride it up
because like I need him to keep
inventing things for us right and then
like we could go to Mars one day and I
feel like Mars could be even better than
Cleveland for me like I can really
escape my problems then you're not gonna
go to Mars no I would never no well my
god no I would get wasted way too
homesick like ya know I can never do it
can barely leave the country yeah I'll
wait for this planet to burn down before
I go to Mars there's like so much of the
world that I haven't seen yet like you
will take me a lifetime before I want to
go to Mars I haven't seen jack [ __ ] I've
been to LA New York Illinois and like to
other states you know I've never been to
Chicago really yeah you would really
like it you think so yes like it might
be your new Cleveland
perhaps no for real like
a cleaner nicer more spread out less
packs really good food like it's like a
better version of New York sorry oh
don't come at me I gotta go I need to go
when like Claudio goes with charity to
her Chicago shows yeah she's doing
Cleveland Show and I actually don't
think I can go really yeah that's your
dream I guess I could go I could I could
make it work things around yeah yeah I
could move I could move things through
Cleveland anything anything Leland and
the Cleveland Cavaliers and the Theo's
that have a Lear that's true and I just
feel like it's obvious a lot of try this
morning oh I'm not okay alive if you
haven't seen where did you see it in the
toasters um no Claudia put it on right
yeah guys you have to see this Theo
filmed a commercial for some pet food I
think was her Petco like it's put in
partnership with Petco he's never been
cuter in his whole life it's like he's
like that but I remember so too when he
did it and Claudia was like he was
terrible at he's not cut out for this
and you can tell in this in the chute
like they couldn't get him to sit so but
they made it work but they made it funny
yeah and they made it funny that's just
the entire personality there like she
look at Theo he's not a good boy until
he has his pet code tree it's so good
I'm saadia in it look at that second
pretty sure because I'm just being like
restless yeah I'm so obsessed with Theo
and like I don't think I could ever love
a thing more than I love him and it's
like I'm gonna have children one day and
they're gonna have to live up to that
sort of lab I how we are with my dog I
like I don't know how I think I look
forward to loving something more but I
don't know how I possibly I or obsessed
like every time I talk about how much I
love my dog my brother's just like Tibet
just gonna die one day I'm like what the
literal [ __ ] is your problem
I was your dog she's only three she just
actually her birthday was last week so
she's my assistant brought over little
party hats and dog treats and we
celebrated and I basically I got mr. M
picture yeah for my story I've heard hat
so that was like so good and well
curated see how much time you like you
spend a lot of time I spend them unlike
anyone elses I I definitely spend more
time than like the average person but
it's not like I'm spending so much time
that it's like a hassle like I do
everything really really fast yeah but
even one of my blogger friends she was
like why he put so much effort into your
instagrams
and I'm just like I just like enjoy it
like I like it like I love that like I
love curating the way it looks like when
I had a myspace like it was the most
bomb-ass my place you've ever seen like
I like to love like I love that [ __ ]
yeah so I just do I go the extra mile no
and I feel like it's really appreciated
yeah like and it also makes you stand
out
thank you so speaking of like your whole
life we have so many questions for you
okay what are your favorite brands
makeup clothing skincare you want to
know my favorite makeup brand favorite
makeup ooh
I'll do a new one I just started using
nude sticks have you ever used nude
sticks now I'm a habit like it takes me
a while to like yeah well I feel like
makeup is just so fun to try something
that's Jo - but nude six are basically
like these like little like literally
sticks and so I literally have the blush
the bronzer and the highlighter on right
now and I've never been able to use like
a contour stick ever it's soap but like
for some reason this works so I
literally like brown bringing down did
they send it to you and that you're
obsessed
yeah like actually and I saw a Mirada
use it in her vogue thing and then like
I said you know when you see something
in the milk starts all yeah I had to get
the mini mini Beauty Blender because I
saw Brianna jabbing her inner eye
concealer which they have bunch of those
in every zone and you don't need one in
your life like at all but it actually is
really helpful because I do feel like I
get clumps yeah and sometimes I like how
that looks but other times like just
having a white dot like it kind of like
brightens the eye right sometimes I
don't get like the concealer right here
and here yeah when I'm like for a fresh
like Sunday morning look it's cute but
like going out at night like I'd rather
neutral later there yeah thing yeah but
I like nude sticks saber to try it
favorite clothing brand I will I always
have to say my own so say XLE favorite
skincare line skincare I I know it's
expensive but I'm really obsessed with
lemare right now I'm so obsessed with
lemare and like like I actually really
[ __ ] you work with them which is a dream
yes I just started which is like my
boyfriend takes full credit for because
his a girl from his high school like
works there and she's a maid saying and
so he thinks that he made the
introduction as if like I would have
never been able to work with Lamar
without him but they're amazing they're
so amazing working with them us
amazing their products I act some
obsessed with like the the cream this
thing that screen standard cream but I
only use it like when I can go to the
airport and steal some from duty free
because one cuz it's expensive but two
because like that's what I'm gonna need
later in life like I need to save it I
don't want my skin to become immune to
it like I'm saving it for when I really
need it I know right now the stuff that
I use is doing a fine job right and then
like when I get to that level of like I
need that extra moisture it's like so
rich and it's like it's not
I don't need it yet it's like games it's
a luxury but I also like truly believe
like what you do to your body like in
your 20s dictates how you look in your
30s I agree so that's why I like I'm
like hoping that at least like my
obsession with skincare like pays off
later in life totem you know yeah so
like I don't know maybe I'm like lie to
myself I don't know but now hair is
definitely like worth die I feel like I
feel like I've always taken like decent
care of my skin like even in college
like take my makeup off put them I'm
like moisturizer but I wish I started
using under-eye cream like even earlier
I know see I just started it's just like
it's such a weird step it's like such a
pain to zits like a small area I don't
know I'm trying because I got like a
really dry patch under my eye so I just
was putting on moisturizer to make it go
away and now it's like I really feel
like if you're in college like I would
recommend an under eye cream even
Kiehl's avocado cream yes I love the
kills avocado right anything crazy I
bought one over a year ago and I still
have so much left so you just go right
and use like this thing the way this one
guy and you just you pat cuz it's too
like your least strong finger right so
okay if you had three days in LA what do
you suggest you and you're seeing it's
hard because it's basically like there's
parts right so there's like Malibu's
over here but then West Hollywood's all
the way over here so I think you should
do based on like what your five is like
if you want to don't go to Hollywood
look you can go to West Hollywood but do
not go to Hollywood whatever you do
what's in Hollywood like you know like
the stars on the free with the Walk of
Fame
and I don't think another Hollywood sign
it's the most disgusting place it's like
going to Times Square
okay but like okay it's just my friends
even when she's like you know when we
visited you I know you didn't want us to
go to Hollywood so we went this time and
like oh my god like why they we were
there for two minutes
like it's disgusting but West Hollywood
is amazing Beverly Hills so like if
you're a shopper go to like Rodeo Drive
in Beverly Hills
if you're a beach girl go to Malibu it
just like it depends yeah you could do
like one day and each like have the IV
Shay like yes go to Malibu Miley Cyrus
one day realize about really Hills the
next day exact rules the next day in
West Hollywood ago to Vanderpump rules
or like something like that like go
maybe look for a drink like don't go for
the food the foods like na curry but the
vibes are finest it's exactly like go
for just like a little you watch
Vanderpump rules
oh my god yes it's so good it's like
it's actually my first Bravo show that I
started watching really yes like years
ago and like I've just been getting more
and more into everything my new
obsession right now is flipping out as I
haven't watched it since I was younger I
don't watch I don't do home stuff but
you're so know but it's it's not even
about the [ __ ] home it's just Jeff
really oh my god yeah it's just the way
it's it's I'm laughing out loud at him
it is so it's basically just about how
like his home life so if you start from
last season because the new season just
came out you could just like watch them
like have the baby and then it's just
like all this like fighting and this is
the way they I mean listen like he's an
[ __ ] but it's hysterical it's not
about the house okay
okay I can appreciate that yes how do
you feel about the kissing booth do you
love it as much as the world um have you
seen it oh my god Cameron and I haven't
watched it and like Joey Joey and camera
and Cameron's my boyfriend
enjoy King are literally best friends
like they are each other's best friend
like if you go on Cameron's youtube
channel it's like the BFF tag it's like
Joey and Cameron like their best friends
and Cameron hasn't seen it either no and
like the day it came out we were like
traveling and we're like okay should we
watch it and we like watch like the
Avengers that I was like we were at this
family and so we just like have I
haven't seen to all the boys I haven't
seen your friends with no Wes I was
gonna ask you to choose between two all
the boys and kissing booth cuz that's
like where it burns out right now the
own see I would come from a different
side of things of like my friends
produced to all the boys I loved before
so I've known about this movie for years
and like I read the script like it those
are like my og people in LA that have
taken care of me so I just have to pick
that movie because it's like my people
produced it totally but I'd like it's
nothing against Joey because I've she's
literally most kind of person ever know
she's so cute and we love we love both
films and you know why can't we enjoy
two good films because we never got
anything and we're very passionate about
right but here's my question for you so
a lot of like rom-coms come out these
days especially like straight to netflix
whatever I guess it's viewers in the
past like as in like two weeks right but
also I get yeah I guess it's anywhere so
they've been working on this movie for a
while like both of them did they ever
think it was ever gonna be like this
level no like I was literally with one
of the producers of to all the boys last
night and I was like did like isn't this
insane like it's just so it's I don't
know if like something's happening we're
like maybe it's just like people are
obsessed with Netflix right now like
it's just crazy like they were just like
movies at one point it wasn't like okay
like these are gonna go viral all right
looks like and even I remember like Joey
literally had maybe like almost a
million followers and watching her go
for everybody and I need two to eight
million in like she she wasn't expecting
it at all yeah it was insane it was
crazy dream 7 million followers
overnight you guys we can get there for
me at Jackie O problems yeah
like just do a Netflix original like my
assistant was like why don't you do a
Netflix original movie I was like do you
think like that's how it works I'm like
I have to like get the audition and like
it's a whole process I'm like [ __ ] up
like I got to go do one I'm like shut up
that's like me I want to be in a
hallmark movie yeah I know and I don't
think I would get 7 million followers
know maybe I should have Internet I
should be enough Netflix is like
versions of the hallmark movies that are
happening out yes oh my god I would be
great in a Christmas movie
like I said lip your little low bun like
a nice like white cozy sweater by the
fire even though you're Jewish like you
would like really bring the family
together no totally I'm like I'm all
about holiday vibes like I would crush
it okay that's my new going like that is
a Netflix hallmark movie yes because
that's where the real success is exactly
okay where did you get your neon sign in
your apartment your decorating skills
are next level but where'd you get any
outside uh toaster okay see I don't know
where I got mine answer oh really
it was like two years ago I like I like
custom-made it or something so wherever
good just go from them okay well no it's
on our Instagram but thank you for
someone that has an office job in the
morning in a waitress in the afternoon
11 shifts a week how do you sit what is
your
nice for staying away from feeling
overwhelmed oh my god oh I'm like the
worst person to ask this because I feel
like I'm constantly overwhelmed my new
trick is therapy it's really great I
just started and it's just like having
someone to like talk to that is it like
actually wants to listen
obviously that's scheduling another hour
in your life which like seems
overwhelming but I feel like a lot of
like I feel like we just like as humans
we're just so structured now to just not
take care of ourselves like at all I've
got any level it's like when our car I
always say your car light goes on and
you're like oh my god I take my car in
but then you get a cold and you're like
I'm fine and then you look feel
depressed and you're like it doesn't
matter it's not real and so it's just
like this weird like like our tangible
things come first like our health comes
second but like our mental health comes
last and so I just feel like it's being
not overwhelmed you just really have to
like figure out like a real structure to
balance like taking time for yourself
and all this stuff because it's like we
just live in a world where like no one
gives a [ __ ] about how you feel and so
like if you're not gonna take care of
yourself like no one else is gonna give
a [ __ ] and so that's why it's like I pay
for therapists so much she cares cuz I
pay her to care and like you could talk
about yourself without feeling guilty
like I hate dinner with my friends and
I'm like wow I talked about myself like
way too much oh I get so much anxiety
yeah I'm like did I talk too much about
myself I'm like did I ask them enough
questions about their self like yeah I
always like go like in my head suck and
you never wanna be that person that only
talks about yourself and like smarter
people are listeners and so you're like
okay I want to be smart it's like let me
listen yeah it's like a whole thing it
is a whole thing damn
and that lights always are you doing
like what are you up to like what what
are you working on and I'm just like a
million things scrap we just like talk
about normal [ __ ] right now I'm like
what are you working on oh I don't care
like I'll like wait for it to come out
really wait til you ask me what I'm
working on um also I meant to ask you
Joey and Jacobs still together right yes
how cute are they cute cute I don't know
I don't see them hopped in together okay
that's fair um she I don't know like we
don't really like hang out the four of
us she look wants us to go on a double
date very recently but they're just like
always like working and stuff like Joey
leaves to go shoot something for like
four months and like a week some like
see ya bye understand how
minimize distractions and stay focused
when you have so many different projects
going on simultaneously
can you tell them really good at advice
no however for me yeah got a chemo cloud
see I'm a Google Calendar what I know
that you're not but like see the thing
is is that like my management runs it
for me okay so like oh hey having a
manager was choice yes like I have an
agent and then I have a manager but I'm
multiple on all those things and so
technically I am my own boss even though
they work for me I feel like I work for
them yeah because it's like I'm younger
and like yeah and they're like yeah like
and so it's just it's really hard like
I've gone like two calls in the past
like two months for my manager it's just
being like I mean you talk like we feel
like you're not focused like what's
going on and I'm just like I feel like
you're so focused I'm like what do you
mean up like I do one [ __ ] thing wrong
and it's like I feel like I'm Satan but
I think it's like it's balance like what
people always like come in my DNS
they're like oh really you work so hard
like you're watching Bravo and I'm like
I can be on my computer and watch Bravo
at the same time like these persons
Bravo is work for me and also if you're
watching Bravo on posting younger
stories technically you're creating
content therefore you are working thank
you I like people are like what do you
think about The Bachelor well then I
have to watch it right so let me want
like your bachelor stuff I like I used
to be like really into it but it's just
like it's been so hard
yeah the Paradise is hey Paradise was
good I mean all the drama is just like
out of control and like I haven't very
passionate about Colton as a bachelor
you're here the brightest I'm half here
for it okay what cuz I've heard things
about him and real life from people mine
I might show him um I've heard things
about like he's like very like
controlling like I had a friend that was
like on a shoot with them and apparently
he was like Ali like his ex-girlfriend
he was like a Lycan I've heard yeah he
would have heard of her doing the
backflip
she's like mm-hmm that was not good on
you like that makes you look big like
just like very like controlling stats
not good I also heard that she had an
engagement ring on so I'm like what is
this like story we're telling I'm right
are you really a virgin
have you really never been engaged
before are you a really straight I'm
like
I am passionate about using the bachelor
because it needs to come to an end right
I need you to find a wife I need you to
lose your virginity and I need to figure
out who you are because if it doesn't
work out after this I'm not buying
anything you're selling it yeah you have
one chance right now
honestly like Aly Raisman like needs to
do like a sit-down with Diane Sawyer and
the other side and I'll the tea yeah she
has it a hundred percent it is burning
anything weren't you so long she ignored
him me on a Mack truck he's like
whatever was above it she's above it but
like he is The Bachelor now like for
four months he will be the most watch
man on television maybe address it now
yeah I also know girl going on The
Bachelor you do is she toaster I don't
know I don't know her what she's a girl
girlfriend's sister got it and my
boyfriend told me so I can't say who it
is but he was like so-and-so sister's
going on The Bachelor but until he seems
okay well do you think called him a
licker yeah oh my god I'm dead can you
make her a toaster we gotta get toasters
like oh I will force her to be at oh
great and oh I will drag her to New York
City it's Han I think she'll get far
she's very pretty
what is your favorite healthy restaurant
in LA um I mean sweet green is just easy
but also a creation with a k-ville
reaction cool did you ever have college
dropout guilt how long did it last if
you did this is how I get over my guilt
I never dropped out I just stopped going
there is a button where did you go I
went to DePaul University Chicago there
is a button online that says drop out I
didn't [ __ ] click it I just never
signed arse in class drop out it's like
canceling like drop out of school
whatever I'm gonna do it for snitch is
never dinner yeah by the way I yelled at
her and diems last night okay I was like
should be here today I was like why
aren't you here she's like I'm so sorry
I'm like I'm filing a report like I
don't know I was telling her I was like
I FaceTime Claudian then last night I
yelled that snitch like it's been a
family affair the past you know I really
appreciate but I never really need the
help I what's called a lot of people
like will be like well what happens like
if Instagram goes away like you have
guilt if like you don't have a college
degree and like I mean listen like I'm
not out here try to be a doctor like I'm
like I'm not trying to be a psychologist
like I'm just trying to be a life style
beauty fashion actor like anything that
I like I could work a marketing I could
work is pretty so there's all these
things so like I don't feel
because I feel like I supplemented my
education like I was and people don't
know like I worked in an office like I
was an intern like the people that made
to all the boys that I loved before like
I interned for that company like I was a
producer and a writer at that company
and so I really like to surrounded
myself with like people that like know
what they're doing I learned the
industry for a year and then I started
like acting and doing all that stuff so
it's not like I just like dropped out
and like moved to LA and was like your
fingers over the mess I worked my ass
off for two years and then I was like
whoo and I got drunk every day but I
waited yeah so it's fine okay that's
good advice
so we've spoken to you about this before
revolve you ever up there well we like
love stalking the trips you've said that
they are truly fun yeah what's your
favorite thing about working with
revolve going on the trips like I really
do like the people like the girls that
work at revolve are just like so much
fun and they're so nice and like once
you're like and you're just like kind of
in you know and it's like they kind of
put you on trips like with girls that
you're friends with so it's not like an
IKE requests like I can toast you can
hear across here but like yeah so like
what happened was is like me my friend
Claudia not your Claudia my Claudia we
always go together and like for a while
we weren't getting plus ones cuz like we
were each other's plus one and so like I
think it because we were like we're like
legitimately life and so we kind of like
made our friends right away with the
revolve girls and then we like started
to kind of like go on those trips and
you can like see like who's going which
weekend of the Hamptons or like whatever
and so you can kind of like request to
go certain weekend with certain people
but like we all go to Coachella together
and like everyone's friends and like
even if you're not like you meet then
like that's how I met all the bachelor
girls and stuff cuz I just like the
Raval girls we know you love the
bachelor like let's go like they're so
chill yeah and they drink a lot like a
lot and so it's like just bottles and
bottles and it's like not that I drink a
lot me and Claudia like actually take
fake shots because like we don't wanna
like piss anyone off we're like yeah
we're so grateful to be here
whoo just like cuz like we just can't
keep up but it's it's truly a good time
it's not just like for Instagram right I
think that that's the vibe that we've
all gotten you guys I'm like I want to
convince I like want to force them to
like invite
so totally like I think you guys need to
do some investigative journalism yes and
when we talked about obviously what
happened yeah it says much you're like
no bueno and we were also saying that
they had recently reached out to us
about like working together and we
haven't heard back and we're like well
now we're not gonna hear anything but we
actually heard back that day and we are
working with them so yeah we're going on
a trip yeah but I'll start you got to
plant the seeds trust yeah it took me a
year to get two trips totally so I just
like hustlin and Mabel's fiu in a year
she would be here at Coachella and
Bermuda what has been the best part of
launching XLE and feel just finally
having something tangible to share with
people like I've never even I've been
doing this since 2011 and I've never
like like yeah movie is technically like
here like watch this but like having
like tangible stuff it's just like
really exciting that also would like the
creative process of it always like a
dream come true so I won't waste your
time just being like well but it was
like it was amazing and it's like really
knowing that it's like the beginning
yeah I know that's that's so exciting
because like we have more collections to
come like this is just the first drop of
clothes and there's like so much stuff
coming so it's just like there's you
know it's like a year and a half like
I'm working on something right
I mean think I'm not your project I'm I
get my that [ __ ] I'm like no like for
real like I have something coming soon
and now it's here like I don't mind a
secret but this is my thing about secret
projects like when people are like
secret project I'm like oh but I just
want to know when the thing launches
tell me this is the secret project you
are going I need to close the book on
the secret project yes oh I'm down for a
secret project when I find out what it
yes and I think I'm very good at that
because I'm like okay I'm gonna like
spill the tea today I'm gonna tell you
what's going on and then like there's
like one secret project that like I
never got to close the book on because
they just like didn't come to fruition
right and that I guess showed to
themselves right on wunderbar and so the
honesty I appreciate as well as if
you're pretending like you know we're
working on it right or that like that it
you never said it to begin with
you know like yeah I just like it's like
I because I also hate that looks like a
lot of like like my biggest pet peeve is
girls in LA like with like sides which
is like what you want to in with like
the part of the script okay I suppose
like three pages of like two scenes or
something and it's always girls like oh
my god like working on something I'm
like no you're not you're going on out
of the shine cuz I street those are
sides you don't you're not working on
anything besides trying to get a job and
so it's always just it's
everything is such smoke and mirrors and
like such a facade that like that's why
I tried to like tread lightly it's like
I just don't want to be that that person
that's like thirsty I'm like no no like
I really am working like I promised like
I'm gonna give you something then I get
anxiety if things get delayed I'm like
yeah I'm like it's coming I swear and so
you don't wanna count your chickens
before you have they happen but you also
like don't you want people to get
excited and don't want only like not
prepared right for what is that my
friend did it - I was like you did not
hype this stuff enough I was like all of
a sudden you were like dropping like
merch and I'm like no one had any idea
yeah I know I got distracted I'm like
well now I'm like it's kind of
anti-climatic so you do got to hype it
up yeah just it's the fondant alabama's
yeah okay final question from like a
very prestigious influencer or Lauren
Elizabeth what do you love about Jackie
I come to this when I was drunk last
night um my favorite things about Jackie
one I appreciate that you mean my
friends love affirming each other so
like this is really easy for me one I
appreciate your fashion sense
you're always have like a bomb outfit
from head to toe like I this is probably
like the most interesting thing I'll
wear Alma that means so much coming from
you I feel like you're always dressed
head-to-toe even in your casual like
high-waisted jeans no you always just
have a little t-shirt no you always have
a look look there's always a full look
okay I love how fast you talk because I
talk fast as well I just love how open
and honest you are about who you are and
you take you don't take no for an answer
I also like that you're like a digital
personality that's truly pioneering the
game like look at what you've done like
I'm in this studio I'm on the morning
toast like you guys are really making
moves and you're not just like trying to
get that Instagram brand deal money and
you you know you are about to be a wifey
so like it's not like you can't go on
The Bachelor but I feel like you
wouldn't because you have a show to run
and you and Claudia are really changing
the game and you're doing my favorite
people on the planet oh my God thank you
so much that is so sweet you are one of
our favorite people like a hundred
percent yes I mean you're definitely one
of our favorite toasters
thank you I tried you actually listened
to the show and I'm so glad to hear
about the movie you literally know
everything I like I know every never
spoken that I'm a psychopath like I feel
like I get like anxiety of like how much
I like people to support people so it's
like I get anxiety when I'm like DM and
Claudia being like I'm just like so
proud of you guys I think you're so
talented and I'm like Claudia's going to
think I'm a freak like I'm in a toasters
group I listen to the toe
like I'm just someone I'm like woman's
supporting a woman and so I get I hope
my if I'm your friend like I hope you
the [ __ ] up like I'm not like the
opposite of that at all so I'm like I
get anxiety that I'm like I thought like
I'm too into the toast like I need to
like calm down like I need to like yeah
like literally like that's why I don't
comment at the toasters group looks like
I have the t2 because people are like
sure and what's going on
done oh like Ashley sky lit yeah was it
Jacobs yeah I'm sorry yeah yeah anyways
thank you so much for being here an hour
and 15 so for all you commuters in LA
sake traffic yeah welcome I'm sweating
um congratulations on the tunic lines
I'm so you sent me a box of stuff I'm so
excited to wear it and like this is
everything I literally like just assumed
it was whatever yeah just clothes
evolved or something not so stylish love
a little good Leopard thank you oh my
goodness you guys we won't be back
tomorrow because it's Yom Kippur and I
have a huge pit I thought that's it look
oh my god I don't think my boyfriend
fasts but we will be celebrating I
literally have never dreaded it so much
as I do right now like I'm planning my
whole evening around it I need some good
stuff to watch I'll finish billions I'm
gonna stay up really late so I can sleep
really eat a lot today though right
tonight and then I stopped eating after
dinner good luck at sundown I'll stay up
really wait wake up really late go to
Temple break fast also another thing I
love about you I just love how you guys
are open about your spirituality well
right thanks and I feel like we always
say like I'm like I feel like a lot of
people who are chat hosts not that many
but have never like really met a Jewish
person before and don't really like
really yeah and we've met toaster to
where like I've never met a Jewish
person oh so we're just trying to
explain the religion a little bit I like
appreciate everyone else's religion I
just feel like religion like it's just
yes so it should be about like spiritual
thing and something bleeding in a higher
power like it's a nice thing to get out
of our own [ __ ] heads for a sec yeah
especially 2018 like having a good luck
morals and like doing like nice
traditions and stuff it's like yeah it
grounds you I feel like so as much as
I'm not looking forward to Yom Kippur in
the past
hopefully on Thursday I'll be a better
person you guys and all of my cell be
absolved gonna be my things you're
literally gonna be so late as a photo
where hallway okay thank you again thank
you
see you Thursday we will be joined by
Leeanne Locken and Lauren Bushnell
almost confirmed okay
you